è da tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi non siamo
in un nuovo video non me lo sarei mai
aspettato vero allora ragazzi vi spiego
la situazione in breve adesso
innanzitutto mi scuso se oggi non ho
fatto uscire il video come al solito ma
perché i ragazzi sto preparando una cosa
che sono sicuro vi piacerà da morire
allora vi spiego praticamente 7 dicembre
quindi qualche giorno fa è stato il
compleanno del canale abbiamo certamente
ho fatto un anno su youtube e per questo
evento ragazzi ho deciso di fare una
live che nella chiedevate da tantissimo
che prima sarebbe un evento nel quale io
gioco in diretta e voi mi vedete giocare
mentre sto giocando in diretta come se
vedesse un video mio come quelli che
faccio di solito solo in diretta c'è una
cosa non ho mai fatto è la cosa più [ __ ]
di tutte quante ragazze che potrete
partecipare tutti quanti alla live come
se fosse veramente invitati a una festa
di compleanno diciamo e per partecipare
ragazzi intendo che potrete tutti quanti
entrare nella partita nella quale sto
giocando e giocare proprio con me in
diretta mentre farò lo streaming e
quindi ragazzi uscirà una cosa epica
questo è sicuro farò anche un momenti
epici della live sicuro perché c'è
usciranno delle cose fantastiche di che
cosa ragazzi che per giocare ovviamente
dovete avere i giochi che che andrò a
fare allora sono andato a scegliere per
ora sono due o scelto due giochi free to
play quindi grati uscente più divertenti
che ho trovate abbastanza leggeri quindi
non richiedono chissà che cosa di
prestazioni ma per evitare che poi con
iniziare una live se nessuno sa i giochi
ancora dobbiamo aspettare tipo mezz'ora
che qualcuno se gli scarichi ho deciso
di dar veli già adesso il link vi
trovate nella descrizione chiunque di
voi voglia partecipare alla live set e
liv chiunque può farlo anche tu anche tu
che stai guardando video in questo
momento sì proprio tu tu perche quella
faccia triste non essere triste fammi un
sorrisino bambin sorrisino quello lo
chiami un sorriso vabbè ragazzi la
smetto comunque il link per partecipare
per chiunque voglia partecipare ripeto
neanche la nonna se volete partecipare
anche lei li trovate nella descrizione
di questo video qui invito game i
ragazzi sono due sono ward frame
e panza sono due videogame che a mio
parere sono parecchio divertenti che ho
visto il parlamente se cliccate nei
league che va messo nella descrizione vi
farà registrare l'account levy
registrate dopo che vi siete registrati
vico rapporti del download del gioco è
niente voi potrete giocare una cagata
assurda vi ho scritto anche le
istruzioni di sotto ma veramente una
stronzata dovete cliccare nei link nella
pagina che vi si aprirà a creare
l'account dopo che l'avete creato vi
farà scaricare il gioco una cagata
pazzesca vabbè comunque scelto questi
due perché mi sembravano veramente il
free to play divertenti ho scelto fritto
breve per far partecipare per i mente
tutti perché è ovviamente comprare un
videogioco per un evento sarebbe un po
una stronzata quindi mettiamo free to
play così almeno chiunque può
partecipare ragazzi i link sono quelli e
non sono anche arrivata la cosa più
epiche ragazzi e se parteciperete in
tanti nella mia partita la live nel
senso vi connettete tutti sull sarà una
roba a livello mondiale perché non è mai
esistito non ho mai visto una live nel
quale si connettono tutte queste persone
quindi ragazzi sarà una cosa pazzesca e
mi è stato detto dalla world tournament
che organizza praticamente queste live
di massa ovviamente registrerà in
diretta a registrano anche loro questa
20 in diretta perché se veramente
raggiungiamo questo risultato ragazzi di
tanti partecipanti quindi se in tanti vi
create l'account partecipate
probabilmente andremo tutto in diretta
mondiale anche su world tournament sarà
una cosa fa io veramente non uso pensare
i ragazzi se per caso qualcuno di voi
non può partecipare ma ma si crea
comunque l'account per darci una mano a
spingere sta cosa qui
sarah sarebbe veramente gradito l'unci
milione ci mettete pochissimo 6 volt se
volete ovviamente non vi sto mica
obbligando però sappiate che se lo fate
non lo so uscirà una cucina e una cosa
epica se riuscissimo ad andare veramente
in diretta secolare ragazzi è più il
vostro compleanno del canale non il mio
perché alla fine chi compone veramente
il canale siete tutti quanti noi e
quindi ragazzi grazie accetto l'invito
have se volete partecipo
i ragazzi difetto chiunque voglia
partecipare di lì che sono nella
descrizione chi non vuole partecipare
può tranquillamente seguire la live
come ultima cosa ragazzi linking
descrizione sono gli ho messi su byte
l'isu bit.ly che avrebbe un sito che
conteggia anche il numero di click
quindi ragazzi se vi registrate
registratevi cliccando su quei link qui
sotto
perché alla fine uscira il numero
complessivo di tutti i partecipanti e e
se saranno veramente tanti potremo
veramente andare in diretta oltre al mio
light e qui i ragazzi non faccio mai
questi tipi di vino a livello
informativo non li faccio mai perché non
ufficialmente non mi piacciono tanto
però questa volta dovevo farlo perché
sennò ci trovavamo sabato quando dovevo
fare la rai perché non c'è veramente
nessuno che aveva il gioco quindi non
potevamo giocare quindi ragazzi
preparatevi già adesso perché sennò così
almeno non dobbiamo aspettare e sarà una
cosa fantastica io veramente non vedo
l'ora dal tipo ogni gol forse anche
meglio non lo so io veramente non me lo
so spiegare cazzo e quindi ragazzi ci
vediamo sabato mi raccomando fate girare
il link se volete
così almeno partecipiamo il più
possibile scusatemi servito di oggi era
così ma doveva assolutamente farlo
comunque da domani si parte
tranquillamente e quindi ragazzi se
video è piaciuto e se siete eccitati per
la five
lasciate un commento mi piace anche a
cacciari facebook e con i video trovate
la descrizione se non vi siete
registrati registratevi per partecipare
e noi ci vediamo non possiamo più bei
ragazzi
[Musica]